what's up Wolfgang Congrats again to bra
or draw for being the first winner of
the infinity war blu-ray giveaway for
the rest of you don't worry the giveaway
still continues I'll be giving out a few
more copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts on
the video and of course your favorite
superhero so there's been a lot of talk
recently on how to take Marvel into the
cosmic universe after Avengers 4
obviously there are new characters
coming in and we have characters going
out whether that be because of death
retirement we have actors with contracts
up who knows but we kind of have an idea
of who our options are to be able to
take the MCU into the cosmic universe
many people believe that it's going to
be Thor but I'm not so sure and the
reason I'm not so sure is because I'm
not so sure Chris Hemsworth is going to
even continue to act anymore
we know that his Thor contract is up and
he hasn't renewed yet at least not that
we've heard now that doesn't mean that
he won't renew his contract and continue
to play Thor especially after the
massive success that Thor Ragnarok had
you would think that he would want to
come back and continue to play his
character however I'm not so sure his
decision to come back is really about
playing Thor I think it's about acting
in general I'm not so sure he's going to
continue to act and if he does I think
he's going to take a major break until
he does his next film and if you think
I'm just saying this to say this I'm not
there's a lot of evidence that he set
himself to back this up for the actors
in the upcoming Avengers 4 movie we know
that the first half of this year has
been all about Avengers 4 and we know
that they're still doing reshoots right
now that's a lot of time and devotion
especially to one movie although it is
probably going to be the biggest movie
ever and for a guy with a wife and kids
that's really hard to be away that much
and he has stated it himself many times
as you could expect Chris Hemsworth is
interviewed a lot and he had many
interviews earlier this year
in several interviews he said that
working overseas has taken a toll on him
and his family he says that he wants to
be there more he wants to be there more
for his kids he wants to be able to take
them to school and he says he may even
retire and just start surfing the rest
of his life and being with his family in
the interview they talked about him
going away for weeks at a time to go
film movies or go do promotions and he
said being away from his young family
was always really tough and his children
used to beg him to not leave and then he
says that was brutal I'd be walking out
of the door and the kids would start
crying don't go I just couldn't handle
it so I'd be like I'll bring you back a
present and they're like oh okay
their mood changes and Chris said with a
heavy heart that they've actually gotten
used to that and you can tell that as a
father he hates it then he stated that
after shooting his new movie bad times
at the L Royal he's going to take six
months off at least and then he added I
may even be off all year maybe it's time
to just cash in and check out and surf
for the rest of my life Chris is spotted
surfing all of the time he even posts to
his Instagram a lot of him surfing and
he even posts with legendary surfer
Kelly Slater and he's even gotten his
kids into it too so it certainly seems
like he's enjoying his family life right
now and maybe a good little break is
what he needs or maybe he'll just throw
in the towel and call it quits spend the
rest of his life surfing and hanging out
with his family I don't actually think
that he will stop acting all together
but I do think he's gonna take a big
break so I'm not too sure that he's
going to be the one to start Marvel's
cosmic future I'm actually thinking the
guardians of the galaxy
maybe Captain Marvel or even Black Widow
if they decide to take it the comic
route and give her the space stone after
they defeat Thanos you can go anywhere
with the space stone but who knows let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below how long do you think Chris
Hemsworth will take off from acting and
what do you think he's gonna come back
and play Thor let me know your thoughts
and again the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway still continues all you have to
do to enter is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts on this video and your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]